this is uh quintessentially British we
have tea and biscuits and we are talking
PDF yes it's the 30th anniversary of the
release of PDF
I knew it was going to be a success of
sorts but I did not foresee how widely
it is now taken up
but I must add to that I also
underestimated how long it would take
people to Twig what it was for so that
was an extra source of tension you know
so very well David you've been telling
us to go with PDF it's the future well
the future's taking an awful long time
coming
I'm pleased I was right because I am not
a futurologist i
generally
shy away from making definitive
statements that what we'll catch on and
what won't but this one I was convinced
about because
I knew it was the future but I just
didn't quite get right the Gap that
there was
uh between it being released and it
being adopted and largely because even
people in the trade didn't fully
understand what it was doing and the
leave origin extra flexibility it would
give them in what they did I think I've
talked Elsewhere on PDF what is it for
even people in the trade could sort of
well I do everything with liner type
what's wrong with that and I would say
well suppose you could make your pages
of stuff even better
if they could insert material prepared
on kit that wasn't from your favorite
Setter but was adhering to this new
standard called PDF and in certain with
certain rules you could insert bits of
PDF Here There and Everywhere
and they said what by subverting all I
said not necessarily by subverting all
the software you're using but just by
saying I can do an insert here using
this add-on to the plugin and it's
completely self-contained but I can put
bits and pieces Here There and
Everywhere it gave potentially
massive new flexibility
I think what I didn't realize at the
time
was that because in the npdf was a
success it really was instrumental in
changing my career Direction
uh I had
I and my Merry gang of colleagues got
into this because we were computer
scientists we weren't always I was not
thinking at the time of wouldn't it be
nice to do those really smart sharp
documents that Bell Labs can do and that
even when you photograph them and put
them through a photocopier from the
release material that's about this thick
when it comes to the post even if you
vote to copy this again it still looked
good and it looked better than anything
we'd got would it ever be a situation
where quality of that potential became
available to Mere
how should we say
enthusiasts from the wrong side of the
Atlantic PDF came out in 93. that's
correct but is that you've got involved
earlier didn't you yes I did
um
even before I knew about PDF
just as part of reading the Unix
documentation because we'd bought Unix
about three or four years before even
got a little PDP 1134 to get herself
started we were just a computer science
group within a bigger maths grouping it
was only a little machine but it was
ours and it was wonderful and we could
play with it
so it became a strange feeling to be the
proud owner of some Machinery which
basically only made sense that that
money and uh with that degree of
expenditure due to the fact that in an
incredible display of
bounty to us all good old Bell labs and
the highly talented people there
invented Unix as an operating system and
then gave it away because they couldn't
be seen to be making money and using
these obscene quantities of income from
the stream of stuff they shouldn't be
doing anywhere and then using it to try
and put us out of business by
undercutting us on everything we did it
wasn't true but you could see how
Corporate sensitivities were aroused by
companies that were under restrained
and Bell Labs was told you will not
convert yourself into a computer company
you will stay hands off you will help
universities if you help other companies
boy we're going to draw up such a tight
thing because we have got
the entire U.S government on our necks
if we are saying as breaking the
antitrust rules
so it's all worked out extremely well
for higher education establishments I
could see from
the documentation that came with the
Unix that the very lowest level of
output device they had was essentially
what will be given from a daisy wheel
printer Laser Printers were in the
process of being invented by
Hewlett-Packard and by Xerox Park and
others but they were not widely
available yet so if you wanted a
slightly lower quality but good version
you had to change Technologies
completely because by this stage your
genuine typesetter end of things was
beginning the path towards crawling
towards Laser Printers at 6 or 1200 DPI
but that was about the best you could
get and the problem was that if you
went for these other Technologies which
were basically like tele types
typewriter fonts and so on then you
ended up with the your output looking
fairly neat but not the same as it would
have looked if only I could have
afforded to send it off to a proper type
Setter like an autologic apps five or a
linatronic 202 and this machine UK
design is called the linotronic 202 this
was the one step so if you want a few
anecdotes there about how I change my
field simply because of an unlocked for
gift of a proper type Setter that really
could do
972 dots per inch and you didn't mind
the smell of bromo developer and fixer
there you go because I didn't have to
wait that long I could see coming off
the
laser print Mac laser printer in the
early 80s here it was on Plain paper no
chemical processing took about a minute
to image each page but this was clearly
the future it would soon speed up the
chemicals will be like a memory from
yesterday I remember growing up and
people talking about this mythical
paperless office right it was all about
oh we won't be printing things out
everything will be on the screens and of
course we kind of were a lot closer to
that these days aren't we but was that
in thought when things like PDF and
PostScript were coming out oh there was
a lot of debate about
why don't we leave it's all electronic
and just
post the um
script of the paper in front well
they're all in the future David have a
little terminal on their desk in the
exam room and I thought oh no they won't
but this was the idea it'll all be
electronic paper will be sold like
yesterday people would be baffled by
what it was no I didn't see this I
thought it would be an incredible
adjunct to have both electronic and
paper kept alongside each other and I
think this is true even now as you see
in my legacy box here I do try to keep
hard copy
archive versions of things that are
really important as well as locking the
actual document and the software
somewhere safe in the file system of my
Linux machine which is over in that
direction your type setting exams you've
changed your field and you're now
working in document engineer is that
fair that's right how do you get from
there to kind of PDF and Beyond
well PDF was a common factor between the
two I mean the more if you like
important test was whether that we could
produce and distribute a serious Journal
just a little demonstration piece and it
would but at the same time as a
as a what's a word on look for side
effect
we had also got something which was my
point of view was perfectly good low
qual lower quality but for exam papers
you were killing two birds with one
stone
and I thought well
you know this is absolutely great it's
just what we need
for all of the unwashed who can't tell
the difference will get a blurry but
okay
thing off the Macintosh laser printer
everything else if people still cared
and could still tell the difference
could it be sent to a bromide typesetter
but I did forecast it increasingly
people wouldn't be bothered and I could
see coming up on the rails but never
quite quite quick enough
for me to head off trouble at the pass
all the improvements in laser printer
quality I mean you're talking now about
three thousand or two thousand dots per
inch that's I think minimum but in those
days it was wow it's now possible to get
a 600 DPI laser printer you know if
people say well how did you know you
were on the right track Dave and this
time it will go your way well I thought
well just
out of the blue because they'd heard
about what I was doing on the Grapevine
Lord knows how Adobe UK found out what
we were doing but there again by that
time we'd taken on John Wiley's
for the actual experiment and it was not
Beyond
you know
not Beyond possible that some
backlink somewhere had joined the two
together because I did not solicit the
letter from John Warnock and Chuckles
they sent it to me out of the blue you
know if you're not too busy on this
particular day would you just like to
come down and I said well I'd like to
come down but I'll bring the um
John Wiley UK technical director Mark
bide I'll bring him down with me because
I know that he will want to hear what
your plans are one has to remember that
on the other side of the fence there
were Technologies being developed
alongside these that were relevant but
needed bridging points to show people
where you could jump Paradigm as they
were because the big problem was there
was a world of appearance and super
duper PDF and there was a world of
structure even if it's only para or P
from
XML SML everybody wanted
superb quality of appearance
to be digable outable of all this stuff
they also wanted full capability to use
the tags as kind of semantic marker what
is the meaning of this and if you're not
careful you end up with a single source
file with about 27 different
interpretations whether it's purely
structure partly structure trying to
second guess what PDF's gonna do
whatever
the two sides are still not reconciled
not surprising because there was a big
semantic gap between the two
it's all very well to structure it
but that magic thing about how does that
known as tree structure translate into
something visually meaningful and
helpful is another big problem in its
own right everybody your architecture or
whoever it will doesn't matter
how technical this stuff is if it's
anything graphic e vectors
shadowed photographs whatever whatever
this technology is powerful enough to do
it and all it requires is the people who
have adopted this technology not to try
and Corner the market and make it their
own because they won't succeed the whole
reason for Adobe being prepared to give
up some control to ISO was that in a
sense they could moderate and police the
way it developed and it wouldn't just be
seen as an adobe benefit March
and I think they got that right because
what they got was
the status of being the undoubted
experts behind postgroups and PDF
and uh my colleague Matthew as I say is
on the iso Committee in Geneva for quite
a few years and was regularly sent back
to the USA
um saying will you ask the designer of
PostScript what on Earth he was thinking
about and be able to come back and say
that is not a feature it's a bug and in
the course of testing out all our worst
cases to try and keep you ISO happy we
will no doubt run through lots lots more
of these
so it's sort of a robustness now what's
happened is the app has gone in cropped
the image down to a much smaller one
which takes up less space in memory so
like kind of engineering type things
this one is getting creating removing
providing criticizing so like for some
reason these types of words